today on stick to football it is mock
draft Monday time you get all three of
us Matt Melo Connor we're gonna give you
two rounds so Chicago Bears fans get
excited you are in this one fellas we do
have some news and notes to go around
again we're gonna say it every day until
we don't upset anymore please stay home
if you can stay home you'll notice the
show looks a lot different if you're
watching it on YouTube it probably
sounds a little different even we are
staying home we're staying out of the
way do that if you can and we've seen
Sean Payton has coronavirus everyone
basically in the NFL now is telling you
stay home stay out of the way until this
thing is over but guys we do have some
free agent news that I think will affect
the draft the Denver Broncos signed
Melvin Gordon the LA Chargers basically
said now we're going with Austin Eckler
we don't want you back I still actually
think Melvin Gordon is a good running
back I think this was a good signing for
the Denver Broncos they gave him two
years basically eight million dollars
per season
this isn't Todd Gurley in my opinion
Melvin Gordon can still play and now we
see the Broncos giving drew lock I mean
they already had a decent backfield now
they have a very good backfield and I I
agree with you I really like Melvin
Gordon too it sucks for him because he's
still a young running back he just
really played the contract thing poorly
we'll say it that way with Eckler
already there in house and then holding
out last year I think the Chargers got a
little bit of a taste of you know what
we don't need to go pay this guy a lot
of money we actually don't need to pay
him at all and now he gets a two-year
deal with the Broncos I like that
signing a lot for the Broncos though I
think he fits that offense and they
continue to surround drew lock with some
young weapons like this a good team
up-and-coming team in the AFC West that
can make some noise with these new
weapons and it makes you wonder what
they're gonna do in the first round of
the draft now cuz we're there slotted it
feels like they'll have maybe a chance
at one of the top three wide receivers
maybe they take a guy like Josh Jones
upgrade a tackle but at the end of the
day we're gonna find out about Drew lock
very quickly because Courtland Sutton
has developed into a great wide receiver
already like you guys just said now they
have two really good running backs I do
wonder if they dumped Royce Freeman very
very very late pick because it kind of
feels like there's no touches for him
left in this offense when you have those
two caliber high caliber runners yeah
and they've also they traded for drill
Asya move that kind of went under the
radar this have a very good a seventh
round pick for a guy who's like a
perennial crow bowler on the d-line they
add graham Glasgow on the interior they
trade for AJ boy before free agency
they've made some quietly good moves and
it's you know a couple years ago we
consistently trashed John Elway for not
really knowing what he's doing in
between Peyton Manning and now feels
like the last two off seasons have been
pretty good for John it's always been
canned John Elway find a quarterback and
the way drew Locke played last year it
looks like the quarterback fell right
into his lap he tried to pass him up a
couple times hey drew Locke just made it
happen and then he goes to him and he
finds success at the end of the year AFC
West fan over here
the Broncos make me nervous yeah I mean
it all depends on just how good luck
gets but I'm with you Melo especially if
it really comes out of the offensive
line I think it's safe to say the
Garrett Bowls pick was very very
disappointing you know like you guys
said they go out and sign a graham
Glasgow but they lose Connor McGovern
and so it's like they get a small
upgrade there but you know they're
really building this thing and it feels
like it's been a quiet but successful
you know I don't want to say full-scale
rebuild but a retooling in Denver yeah
they did it on the fly and they did it
well I may think a year ago they were
adding Joe Flacco we're like okay and
now it's over drew lock and we're
getting younger and more fiscal on
offense guys how about this one Todd
Gurley goes home they say you can't go
home again Todd Gurley does go back to
Georgia the Atlanta Falcons have added
Todd Gurley and I know we've talked
about this a lot about does he have
anything left in the tank what's kind of
craziest to me Thomas Dimitrov now has
11 former first rounders on offense when
they at when they trade it for laQuan
Treadwell over the weekend her sign
excuse me sign laQuan Treadwell over the
weekend and added Todd Gurley 11 former
first rounders on offense I have to
think that has never been done before
it's a unique way to build a team
because a lot of these first rounders
like adding to Todd Gurley maybe not
what he used to be but the talent is
there
and with Gurley I like this signing
because they're not paying him very much
money I think the Falcons are on the
hook for what six million dollars half
his car Curly's gonna get 11 this year
but they don't have to pay about half of
it so I like that as kind of a
bounce-back year and they've got some
guys in that backfield that can still
carry the load
they were doing it last year with Devon
so Freeman so adding Gurley and giving
him that chance to come back to the
Georgia area I like it he can be
productive hopefully he's resting up and
that knee is healthy I'll tell you that
knee looked kind of scary and the the
rams did a lot of things to hide that
injury and what he was going through but
hopefully he can have a bounce-back year
with the Falcons I would love to see him
lead the league in rushing touchdowns
again and it's a remarkable house
immature off just collects running backs
at this point we were saying it only sat
down with him that I think he's taken
one on day through round three or later
in the draft almost every year yeah
except one year and like the last decade
it feels like four Dimitrov so then he's
peep AIDS about to Freeman which he was
very open about he's like you know I
know you know it's tough you pay a guy
and then he gets her and now they go pay
a guy that has been kind of banged up
but I do think they have a plan for
Gurley where he's not the guy getting
80% of the touches it'll probably be 40
to 50 percent of the touches and they
feel like they can get this offense
going in the right direction and I love
Todd Gurley you know got to interview
him on this show and feel like he's
under you know quietly quietly one of
the more awesome guys in the league so I
hope he could stay healthy and I hope
he's rejuvenated being back there in
Atlanta
yeah and getting behind a better
offensive line I know we talked so much
about the knees and the arthritis and
and I do good point factor that
offensive line
I truly believe is one of the was one of
the worst in the NFL last year I think
it affected Jared golf I think it
affected Todd Gurley so getting him
behind an offensive line where they've
invested two first-round picks where you
have a Jake Matthews who's very good I
hope I think there's a much better
situation for Todd Gurley and how about
the New England Patriots guys they lose
Tom Brady as we talked about last week
he goes to the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
they have Melos man-crush Jarrett's
tittle met quarterback and now maybe a
little competition drum roll here Brian
Hoyer welcome back to anyway I think
they're just setting himself up for
success here you're bringing in Jared
stidham's backup quarterback to kind of
help tutor him I really think that the
Patriots might just roll out with
Stidham I know that I'm his biggest
supporter and it kind of seems like a
joke maybe sometimes I think that's what
the Patriots are gonna do if I mean I
don't know what other quarterback you're
gonna replace him with I don't think
Bella checks a guy that's gonna go say
oh we need to sign a Jameis Winston type
guy
I think they roll with cinnamon I think
the this Hoyer move I mean you could
sign a lot of quarterbacks right now
they decided to bring back a veteran guy
probably to pair with a guy like Jared
Stidham well you need to find someone to
play behind him in case you know the
wheels fall off the bus but it does seem
like right now they're setting up to
give sidam every opportunity in this
offense so you can't just roll in with
just Jarret Stidham you get Brian Hoyer
who's been there before you know they
they love the guy feels like they trust
the guy and New England not I I can't
even I gotta be honest guys I'm not
really quite sure what they what they're
doing are they loading up are they gonna
surprise us and take someone like Jordan
Love in this draft and then develop him
while giving him a shot against Stidham
and then eventually Hoyer as the veteran
there there are so many directions they
can go because you don't bring back Tom
you're not really aggressive in the
quarterback market but you franchise tag
Joe Tunney and signed Devin McCourty to
an extension and pick up his twin
brothers options so they've done some we
want to win now moves they've done a lot
of we're gonna rebuild this thing moves
I think the draft is gonna paint the
entire picture for us with New England I
was talking to some exciting article
come out Thursday about kind of the
timeline of how Brady decided to leave
New England you can look that up in the
BR app and I was talking to someone
after that article came out pretty high
up in an NFL front office and I asked
him the same questions like what do you
think they're gonna do a quarterback
this was Thursday afternoon so was like
you know anything other trade for Andy
Dalton you know is this a Cam Newton
spot he was like this is the most
prepared team in the history of the NFL
you're you think they weren't ready for
this the this potential that Brady was
gonna leave and that kind of left an
impact on me like you know you're right
I'm sure Bill Belichick did not put all
his eggs in the Tom Brady's coming back
basket he had to know that there was a
very good chance that Brady was leaving
it makes you wonder if Stidham is their
guy or if they're waiting for maybe the
price to decrease on an Andy Dalton in a
trade but New England I think an
intriguing team not because we expect
them to go undefeated or have the best
defense in the NFL or anything like that
they're treating cuz we have no idea
what this offense is gonna look like for
the first time in 20 years and they're
sitting right there at pic number 23 I
think a spot where we could see one of
those quarterbacks fall especially if
you know the Chargers don't take a
quarterback
there are four of them I think that our
first round guys to have that pick at 23
that might be where the fourth one comes
off the board you might be sitting there
you know with a guy like Justin Herbert
there or Jordan love sitting there or
maybe they say you know we didn't like
what we saw from Stidham let's take a
chance on a guy like Jacob Eason right
there at the end of the first round
maybe even trading back like they've
done in the past or what if they do the
ultimate Patriots move and take Jake
from I mean honestly would anyone be
like no that's lured by it I mean maybe
not with that first-round pick but maybe
they maneuvered their way back up to get
him I I'm not the biggest Fromme guy
I've been very vocal about that but I
doubt to be the first to tell you I
think he's going in the top 50 picks in
this draft I think so as well or they
liked Baker Mayfield maybe they go Jalen
Hertz Jalen Hertz that's another one
there you go so and they haven't have
crazy options or they just stick with
Stidham you know maybe they've seen him
for a year maybe there's something that
it's like more pieces around him even
after Tom Brady leave so we still have
no idea what's going on with the
Patriots like first is what's gonna
happen with Brady now it's we don't know
what the hell's gonna happen next yeah
I'm gonna stop predicting things because
I was big-time wrong big time alright
let's take a break we come back our to
round mock draft which hopefully we will
not be big time wrong about any of these
picks it is Monday that means you get a
mock draft today a two rounder and we're
gonna fly through the first couple picks
because you guys know it
number one is Cincinnati Bengals I am on
the clock and it is Joe borough at
quarterback I know it's been some buzz
about maybe a trade up we don't predict
trades in these MOX if the Dolphins want
to do it they would take Joe Barrow so
Joe Broz give me the first pick in the
draft yeah and I I think that I'm gonna
be boring here to the Redskins sitting
there at pick number two overall I still
think they're going chase young it
wouldn't surprise me if they go off this
and get somebody else like a Jeff a CUDA
but for right now if you're making me
pick who I think or if I'm putting money
on it I'm gonna say it's chase Young at
number two overall and number three I
mean let's keep this thing moving here
we know it Jeff a CUDA to the Lions it's
hard for me to make another pick here
honestly guys I'm not betting on them
surprising everyone and moving on from
Stafford to take a guy like to it that
has injury risk you can run your defense
through a number one corner like a CUDA
they obviously went out and bolstered up
their secondary even a little bit even
after trading Darius slay
during the free agency waveone period so
the liens end up with a kuda who I
absolutely love in this class and think
is worth every bit of the number three
overall pick number four the New York
Giants this is where I'm gonna change
things up I'm gonna go Tristan to work
for the offensive tackle from Iowa we're
trying to anticipate what the draft will
look like in a world without pro days
without private visits and I think the
lasting impression of Tristan works will
be that historic combine performance
coupled with tape Iowa that is pro ready
some that I've talked about a lot over
the last few years as we've seen Pro
ready programs like Iowa Notre Dame
their offensive linemen to get
prioritized a little bit when it comes
to the NFL Draft I think works is gonna
be seen as we have no idea if there's
gonna be rookie minicamp right now guys
we have no idea what this summer is
gonna look like I feel like teams are
going to be a little more conservative a
little more safe when drafting whoops
may not have the ceiling of Makai Becton
but I feel like he is a good alternative
in that you know what you're getting in
terms of floor and you have the athletic
up side I think you play left or right
tackle I know I played right tackle for
the hot guys but I really feel like in a
world with some uncertainty guys like
you know Jedrek wills I like gingers
Will's a lot I like a Joe Thomas a lot I
think works might answer the most
questions to be this first tactic a I
think with works even I mean Jedrek
wills a guy from Alabama who we all have
as our tackle one here in this class I
think that he is a legit tackle but was
worse he's gonna play somewhere on that
offensive line for the next 10 to 12
years it might be at left tackle it
might be at right tackle it might be a
guard but that dude can find a spot to
play on that offensive line and it just
seems like a Dave gentleman type guy
number five overall the Miami Dolphins
Nnamani Miami Dolphins have done too
much work to pass up on to him right now
I feel like they've looked at him over
the last probably three years had their
eye on this guy they're not gonna let
the medicals scare them away
everybody says that it's good maybe they
can't get him in the house like they
want to but I still think they have to
take to it right here at number five and
number six
since the Dolphins didn't take him the
Chargers will and that's Justin Herbert
this is a team that you know we heard
about some offers for Tom
but at the end of the day you look at
what they have right now I think they're
ready to use a top ten pick on a
quarterback you have Tyrod Taylor in
place there that can hold the fort if
you need to develop Justin Herbert like
Matt said we don't know if there's gonna
be a rookie minicamp right now which
could set back a quarterback prospect
like Herbert but for the Chargers he
only picked this high so many times if
they like the guy they're gonna take him
he's very athletic he has a big arm I do
think he needs some time but I also
think this is the right landing spot for
him as well
number seven I'm on the clock with the
Carolina Panthers they signed Teddy
Bridgewater to a 3-year deal which
seemingly solves their problem at
quarterback they still have backups Cam
Newton is actually still on the roster
they have Kyle Allen and they have will
Grier the offensive tackle position
we've spent a lot of time talking about
Gregg little Taylor Moton both players
picked in the second round of previous
drafts I have no idea how Matt rule
feels about his offensive line but I do
know that they have to get faster on
defense Luke Kuechly retires that they
have Shaq Thompson who's a good player
but they need a difference-maker on
defense I think Matt rule coming from
the college game Joe Brady coming from
the college game they're gonna take one
look at a guy like Isiah Simmons and say
that can be a difference maker because
we don't want to have to game plan
against a guy like that we know how
difficult he will be for the Falcons the
Saints the Buccaneers so you get an idea
Simmons who could shut down slot
receivers he could shut down tight ends
he can rush the quarterback he can spy
mobile quarterbacks we talked about it
on the Friday show Simmons might not be
he might not give you three more wins a
season but I think like a super-sized
Irwin James he's gonna be a difference
maker in a game like against the Lamar
Jackson which were derma James really
showed up I think Simmons has value in
that regard yeah I think so too and with
the Panthers it's so difficult to mock
drafts of what you think they're gonna
do because they could go so many
different ways I know that we've had you
know guys like Derek Brown going there
before we've had the Justin Herbert's
there now with Isaiah Simmons there a
lot of needs on that team even though
they're kind of headed in the right
direction
number eight overall speaking of teams
with needs and going in the right
direction the Arizona Cardinals they've
got the receiver so that need is off the
board now I'm gonna go with Jedrek wills
out of Alabama they have
DJ Humphries at left tackle but I still
think you get wills in house you get him
develop maybe even play him on the right
side hell I'm not convinced he can't win
that left tackle position immediately
this is one of the most athletic tackles
that I've seen I loved his tape and I
think that Kliff Kingsbury is gonna say
this is the guy that can protect our
franchise quarterback for the rest of
his career number nine the Jacksonville
Jaguars this is a team that can go in a
lot of different directions just like
the Panthers here I am curious to see
how much they trust in their offensive
line right now for Gardner Minshew
I think they're very thin at corner but
there's not somebody I would take in the
top ten unless it was Jeff Okuda and he
did not make it here so I'm gonna go at
Jerry Judy this is really a BPA approach
they have DJ charkh there now you have
Gardner Minshew some weapons if you
believe if you believe you want to hand
the keys of the franchise to this guy
and give him a fair shake I think this
pick will either be an upgrade of
offensive tackle or anywhere on the
offensive line or a top wide receiver
they have a lot of holes on defense now
- after the salary dumping and all the
moves they've made so I'm fascinated to
see what this pick is but if I was the
one in the driver's seat I couldn't pass
on Jerry Judy at them at nine overall
Jerry Judy and DJ chart togethers a lot
of fun like that's that's a good start
for your guy gardner minshew that's
that's where you want to be number ten
the Cleveland Browns and offensive
tackle Falls to them I know they signed
Jack Conklin guys they still need a left
tackle so Makai Becton was gonna be the
pick here I think the Browns are a team
that could consider in Isaiah Simmons I
think they could consider a wide
receiver even though I know they have
Odell I know that drivers Landry I still
think a receiver is gonna be an area
that they address somewhat early in this
draft just because there's been some
rumors about maybe Odell gets moved
again if that were to happen then you
would consider a CD lamb here or a Henry
rugs but for me it's offensive tackle
all the way and then you go to
linebacker or safety in rounds 2 & 3
some Akai Becton talked about it earlier
gigantic ceiling on this player a pretty
low floor where he's coming in you hope
the development over summer will pay off
to where he's ready to rock and roll
yeah and sticking with that need at
tackle I'm gonna go with Conners Jets
number 11 overall I know that they
brought in Fame
at left tackle I still think the
offensive line is a huge need and I just
like Tristan whoops I think Andrew
Thomas out of Georgia is another guy
that will find a spot on that offensive
line and can develop and be that left
tackle that you need for the future you
have Sam darn 'old the offense did a lot
of really good things last year I mean
they won a lot more games than I thought
they would
now go protect him keep him from seeing
all those ghosts he was seeing all right
number 12 the Raiders back to wide
receiver here obviously Judy was the
first one off the board number 9 with
Jacksonville with the Raiders at 12 here
I'm gonna surprise some people and
actually go Henry rugs not CD lamb I am
above a believer that Jon Gruden is
gonna value speed and Raiders are a
franchise that has valued speed for as
long as they've been around but I think
with Gruden you've heard the rumors of
the trade interest for Robby Andersen
they addressed a lot of different needs
in free agency yes you brought in Nelson
Aguilar but you need a true
game-changing kind of threat at the
position and I know they need help they
still need help on the defensive side of
the ball as well but it's 12 is where
you're gonna get the most value at this
position rugs is a guy that can threaten
even when he doesn't have the ball he
does so many different things to upgrade
an offense right away so 12 for the
Raiders not CD lamb even though he's on
the board it's gonna be the speedster in
Henry rugs
jagran has seen Tyreke hill on the other
side of field twice a year and half two
years there you go you know what that
you know a speed does and it changes
everything on offense number 13 the San
Francisco 49ers with Judyann drugs off
the board I will gladly take CD lamb for
this offense I think what he can do from
a slant route perspective the braking
routes gonna be fantastic and Kyle
Shanahan's offense lamb is so good after
the catch I know he ran a four or five
oh he runs faster than that with the
ball in his hands the catch radius is
enormous he is a violent route runner
very aggressive at the catch point I do
have some questions about he's never
really seen press coverage he's gonna
have to expand his route tree I think he
can do it it's a matter of what was he
asked to do at Oklahoma versus what he
can do in the NFL so I think lamb is a
player who will get better at the next
level as we see him develop you don't
have injury concerns with this player
really the only question is it's not
that fast and the offense he played in a
college
didn't ask him to do a lot of dynamic
things but I feel like he'll be a weapon
immediately so if you give me Siddhi
lamb Deebo Samuel you got jalen hurd
Gorge Kittel and a hell of a lot of
running backs
Niners offense it's not taking a step
back yeah that that's scary maybe
they'll be able to beat my Chiefs next
time face them now number 30 your
starting number 14 overall the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers this team looks totally
different from the last time we did a
mock drafts with Tampa Bay could have
said they needed a quarterback last time
now that offense looks all set so I'm
going to my big board and I'm looking
out what do they need a lot of the
offensive linemen are gone maybe you
could go there I'm going with a
difference-maker on the defense whatever
position it is a difference maker on
defense and I think that's clay Vaughn
chase on at LSU I think even if you keep
Barrett you can pair those two up much
like the Broncos did a couple years ago
and just say go kill every quarterback
that's out there let Vito Vega dominate
on the interior and chase on been that
edge and get after these really good NFC
South quarter let's Devin white clean up
in the middle exactly and I know
something Matt's pointed out what
Chaisson is he could do a lot of
different things besides rush the passer
he doesn't cover and I'll tell you Todd
Bowles he loves that versatility with
his linebackers I mean the Jets were
hoping they would get that when they
took Darren Lee it didn't work out but I
mean once again bulls is a guy that he
put a lot of value into linebackers
doing a lot of different things so
that's a pic that adds up if they opt to
go defense 15 the Denver Broncos here
none of the top wide receivers are on
the board that's a direction I think
they could go but now you have Josh
Jones sitting here and at 15 I kind of
like him you're upgrading your pass
protection at tackle for drew lock you
could probably plant I mean you'd like
to play them on the left side maybe you
have to play them on the right side
either way with Josh Jones
I think that's an upgrade that they need
not just for this year but for the long
term if you're the Broncos don't be the
team as we've seen the Browns the Jets
the Cardinals do kicking the can down
the road with offensive line when you
have a young quarterback you don't want
to make that mistake solve it now
especially when the board plays in your
favor here - Landing one a guy like Josh
Jones I really do like that pick in it
you know when we were doing this mock
draft yesterday I was like guy Conor
probably OD line here like Josh Jones
though if
you can get a premier player at a
premier position a left tackle you can
get a DTAC loan around to good I would
have if they didn't make that trade
right yeah and so now you get a guy like
okay yeah drill Casey can fill in okay
we know a Bradley Chum that's 26 right
exactly yeah Bradley Chubb coming back
from injury you still got von miller yep
aj boy it just in simmons the secondary
like denver could be scary good next
year it's gonna be fun getting through
this process and seeing where they stand
last big before a break the Atlanta
Falcons at number 16 overall they have
filled many of their needs through
fridge so you bring it Dante Fowler you
bring in Todd Gurley you have a young
offensive line so I'm gonna go to the
secondary this is a little bit of a BPA
pick I know some fans will say why not
addy tackle I really just outlined it
the drop off addy tackle there's a
little bit of one but it's not enormous
the drop-off at corner after CJ
Henderson in my opinion is it's a cliff
when you go from a CUDA it's a big step
to Henderson it's a big step to Geoff
Gladney so to get CJ Henderson here
Chris Harris is gone excuse me not Chris
doesn't Trufant he's gone so now you get
another young guy to go with what they
have I say Oliver who like to coming out
of Colorado a few years ago you got size
and speed at the corner position now we
are back on stick to football and we are
continuing our two round mock draft I am
up number 17 overall the Dallas Cowboys
and they've been active this offseason
with some holes to fill still I'm
looking at my big board and I'm going
with the defensive guy again who can
come in and be very disruptive they
signed Gerald McCoy and I'm gonna give
them another athletic defensive lineman
probably not the one you're thinking of
though Derrick Brown is still on the
board but I'm going with Javon Kinlaw I
think a lot of teams are gonna look back
at that combine tape of Derrick brown
and say oh I actually kind of liked that
kid out of South Carolina he's able to
move I love Derrick brown I love the
tape he's very high on my board but I
think the Cowboys are gonna roll with
Javon Kinlaw here a degree Kinlaw has
the bigger ceiling I really would and I
think for the Cowboys just asking their
guys maybe to pin their ears back and
get after it kianlawl might be even a
better fit there so I like that pick a
lot 18 the Dolphins this might seem like
a reach to some but I think they need an
offensive tackle and I'm not gonna be
the first I'll be the first to tell you
I'm not the biggest Austin Jackson fan
if you need a guy to step in and
contribute from day
but I think Miami has shown that they're
willing to honestly trust the process
here go year by year they feel they
could develop Austin Jackson since Josh
Jones is no longer on the board so 18
might seem early for the offensive
tackle that's considered the sixth best
guy in this class but for the Dolphins
they have a lot of picks and I think
they could take the chance on developing
a guy and I have heard from teams that
like Jackson more than Jones and J he's
got a level of cop thing so I don't
think it would be crazy to see all six
of these guys go on the top 20 picks not
not by the least bit number 19 the Las
Vegas Raiders Melo left Derek Brown for
me I got to do it I know that picked up
some guys in free agency it's like one
year kind of proved it deals one thing
that you heard a lot right before we all
got shut down was the Raiders were not
happy with their defensive line play the
defensive tackle play love their inch
but they felt like Cleveland Ferol and
Max Crosby needed the table set for them
a little bit more so I think defensive
tackle after wide receiver is gonna be a
big point of emphasis they signed two
linebackers now you could go corner here
you could maybe go safety here but for
me the best value was Derek Brando I
think probably everyone has a top 10
player there's just a question about a
guy who doesn't rush the quarterback a
ton but very very good at setting things
up for the guys on the edge yep and I'm
up again number 20 overall the
Jacksonville Jaguars
when you look at the Jaguars they got
Jerry Judy with their first pick so that
receiver need is off the board I don't
love the corners that are here right now
I think that's the place Jacksonville
could go but they also need a linebacker
I think and Patrick Queen still on the
board at number 20 overall this is a
team that we've been given Isaiah
Simmons to a lot in mock drafts if they
can come away with Jerry Judy and
Patrick Queen Jaguar fans should be very
happy yeah yeah that's that's not a bad
deal at all for the jacks in terms of
the rebuild it feels like you got you
bit off a lot more than you could chew
there I mean that's great value 21 the
Eagles
I mean we've said this every show this
is still a team then he's more wide
receiver help and the board keeps
falling in their favor Justin Jefferson
is there I think he's worth every bit of
that 21st overall pick I think for the
Eagles this is a good scheme fit this is
a guy that can do a lot of different
things but most notably help out your
quarterback he's got a great catch
radius
to snag everything he's really tough
after the catch so Justin Jefferson and
the Eagles that's an upgrade after they
lose Nelson Aguilar he's gonna say you
got a guy who can catch now have you
seen I know this is off topic give you
some I know the Eagles fans are wearing
a Galore jerseys around Philly because
they don't want to catch coronavirus
light of the situation yes that's the
best way to do it yeah start doing it
from your home right I agree that is
just good amazing I hadn't seen that yet
number 22 the Minnesota Vikings have
this pick after trading Stefon Diggs to
Buffalo and I'm gonna give them a wide
receiver not necessary to replace Diggs
because at very different player inti
Higgins but someone to help make this
offense a little bit better I think give
you a vertical stretch guy to work
opposite Adam Thielen Higgins is tough
because the pro day was one of the last
ones before the shutdown ran a four five
six not a great time for him but not a
terrible time it's probably right where
we all would have pegged it but his film
is still incredibly good and I think
this year more than ever
hopefully teams are gonna rely on the
film not so much the workouts because
you don't have the big data points for
every player in the class working out
watch t Higgins over the last few years
dominating the red zone dominate 5050
balls play over the top I think he could
give the Vikings off in something it
really needs ya and I'm off again here
with the Patriots number 23 overall and
I'll tell you I don't know what the hell
they're doing they could go in so many
different ways they could take a
quarterback here they could probably
still address offensive line maybe go
receiver again I think the Belichick is
just gonna take a defensive weapon it
seems like that's what he always does
and I don't think they need I don't
think they draft on need ever so I'm
gonna give them Xavier McKinney he just
seems like a Belichick kind of guy they
could come in play some nickel corner
even I don't know what the Patriots are
doing I'm gonna give them one of the
best guys on my board with Xavier I love
the honesty it's like you know what I
always think like I'm honed in like oh
this is an obvious need for the Patriots
and then they go an opposite way so I'm
gonna give them Xavier McKinney I don't
think it's a need I think that's where
they go 24 here the Saints they actually
made this a little easier they went out
and surprised those guys by signing
Emmanuel Sanders I did not see that one
coming at all so a great addition for
the
at great dollar amount that is a plug-in
play number two wide receiver now
alongside Michael Thomas so I love that
ad and in the first round I think it
takes wide receiver off the board for
them so I'm gonna go
Cesar Ruiz interior offensive lineman
played Center at Michigan can play guard
they lost Andrews oh they actually were
able to keep Andrews Pete on a big big
contract but he's a guy that's been
banged up you're really thinking down
the road here you have peed on that
interior you have some pretty good
players at tackle but they still need
one more interior piece in my mind for
the long-term future in Ruiz who might
be one of the better values on the spot
because of his positional versatility
for the Saints where you're going into
the season and you feel good about how
deep you are at wide receiver Alvin
Kamara is healthy Drew Brees is back now
you've loaded up that offensive line
across every single position for the
Saints so this team I know they fell
short last year they were definitely a
disappointment but I feel like we're
gonna be talking about them once again
gearing up for another Super Bowl Super
Bowl run might need to get a safety who
can tackle
that's the question is who do you take
here Melo just beat me to the punch 23
with McKinney I think McKinney would be
a good fit there and then you know going
down our board here it feels like anyone
else you know might be a reach if
Antoine Winfield's medicals are good
that's an exciting one but I think
they'd look for a bigger player on the
back end of their defense definitely
great 25 I'm up again with the Minnesota
Vikings took T Higgins at 22 well now we
address that need at corner after
they've basically retooled their entire
corner position this offseason
I'm gonna go Jeff Gladney we've talked
about it before he's a little bit short
at 5 10 plus sticky at the line of
scrimmage so fantastic of press coverage
you can watch him battle against the
biggest guys in the big 12 over the last
two seasons watch him get it done
notably last year against Hakeem Butler
who's like 6 foot 5 and he's just
rocking him and the collarbone play
after play at the line so Jeff Gladney
not the biggest guy in I know Minnesota
normally favors that but I think what he
can do playing at the line of scrimmage
is something they should fall in love
with yeah you know I'm up again here the
Dolphins third pick in the first round
they got the quarterback they got their
offer by the way they have picked up
everyone a free agency oh I know so
every one of their needs are starting to
get filled in I'm going
give them Kenneth Murray here out of
Oklahoma I know they picked up Kyle van
Noy but I still think that they look at
this defense and save me and we got a
lot to stop with Josh Allen in the bill
Sam darn old over there in my guy Jerry
instead of with the Patriots so Kenneth
Murray it's just too good to keep
falling down and I love what he can do
I really like the linebackers I know
that you guys have heard that before so
with Kenneth Murray sitting there at 26
a lot of people are probably gonna want
one of those running backs I think they
can wait till later now we haven't had a
running back come off the board yet I
still think they can find one later in
this draft 27 the Seahawks here they
still feel like the favorite to me guys
to get the Jadeveon Clowney deal done I
know there's been rumors about the Jets
poking their head in that feels like hey
here's a one-year offer if you want it I
think Seattle makes the most sense for
him so I'm not gonna go edge here I'm
gonna go corner and that is jaylen
Johnson the big press corner out of Utah
he's been a common name at the top of
round two but there are guys you look
across for the first round there are so
many teams they need quarterbacks where
I think we're gonna see you know
quote-unquote reaches here and I like
what jaylen Johnson can do in their
scheme that's the thing too for teams
that want guys that can press that have
size and length and a lot of playing
experience I think he's somebody that'll
start to become prioritized between
those 25 to 35 pick range you know
what's weird for me this year with Utah
they have a lot of players but I almost
feel like I'm downgrading their players
because how much talent is around them
so like I even worry about you know like
together jaylen Johnson like that
secondary was really good or like fotu
and Bradley and I like that they play so
well together it's almost like when you
watch Alabama or LSU you okay well you
know he can do this because the guy
beside him like Chaisson he's set up
sometimes by Rashard Lawrence you don't
normally expect that from Utah but damn
that defense is absolutely loaded this
like eight guys that are probably gonna
get dry really well number 28 the
Baltimore Ravens a team we have
applauded heavily on this show trading
hayden hurst and getting back a hell of
a return getting coleus Campbell getting
Michael bra curse I'm gonna continue
that on defense and go after you tore
gross mottos to play we don't know
what's gonna happen Matt Jude on they
put the franchise
tag on him rumors have been swirling
that that's a tagging trade situation
give me your tag and keep I still feel
like with Jude on an giris mottos they
could play on the same defense both
bigger guys you want their hand in the
dirt I think Jude on gives you a little
more versatility but you're gonna have
to eventually address the edge position
with or without Matt Jude on I think
girls Matos is an exceptional value I do
too and I'll tell you I have a favorite
football team now I know that used to be
a segment of like trying to pick my
favorite team if I didn't have a
favorite team already I absolutely love
the way the Ravens are building this
team the way they run the football what
they have will Lamar Jackson and then
what they're doing on their defense that
is a great team this organization is
looking scary going forward much like
the Tennessee Titans who are up at
number 29 overall they just lost a
defensive lineman and this seems like a
variable pick to me I think they take AJ
epinet and they play him on the interior
they let him get up to about 290 and
they let him just wreck offenses this
team was a couple stops away from going
to the Super Bowl I think they find a
guy that can pressure the quarterback
and stop the run and to me that's AJ up
Anessa
yeah he strikes me as a rebel guy he
really really does I think that's a good
landing spot for him 30 the Packers
still feels like they have a need here
at wide receiver guys I thought they
would come and maybe they do end up
signing a guy like Robbie Anderson and
free agency there's still time to do
that but once again I like how the board
broke here where you can get Denzel Mims
at 30 size and speed I think he's
somebody that I know personally for me
he's caught my eye through the process
more so than the season whether it was
at the Senior Bowl whether it's at the
combine testing and I think in terms of
fit this is a really really good one
with Aaron Rodgers once again because of
that size speed catch radius across from
Davante Adams they have our guy Allen
Lazard there those are three wide
receivers you can get excited about as
Rodgers gets a little bit old
especially in a tithing group that we
don't like anyone this early that's the
problem a huge help for them
31 somehow this works out perfectly I
expect from my team Melo gets picked for
his team 31 the San Francisco 49ers this
is a team we gave them a receiver at 13
feel really really good about that I
know there would be some conversation
about do you go back to the D line here
to replace what you just lost in
DeForest Buckner I don't believe so I
think that's why they paid Arik Armstead
they have not released d4 it seems like
they're content on bringing him back
opposite Knick bosun next year but
coroner is still in need Richard Sherman
hell of a player but is getting older a
killer Witherspoon was a weak link they
did resize jimmy ward but corner isn't
need for me opposite Sherman even with
how well Mosley played down the stretch
with Trayvon Diggs on the board he is a
player that I would probably not put
late first round for most teams but he
fits this 49ers defense so well with his
length his aggressiveness in coverage
his ball skills his speed he is
tailor-made for teams running a cover
three defense like the Niners Ron so
digs here more about value in this
scheme than value overall as a prospect
but could not find a better fit I mean I
know Minnesota fans really wanted him
about a week or two ago I wonder if they
still still after Trayvon Diggs or not
I'm up like Matt said number 32 overall
the Kansas City Chiefs and I'm really
torn here with this pick because I think
the biggest need on the Chiefs board is
definitely going to be corner I'm not in
love with a lot of the corners here and
I would not be surprised at all if Andy
Reid says let's go lock up a guy like
DeAndre swift for the next five years
Jesus let's make this an unstoppable
offense let's add a Marshall Faulk type
running back to our offense but I'm
going to go with corner here I'm gonna
go what's Christian Fulton at LSU I
think the meat is just too much you
really have almost nothing coming back
at cornerback for the Kansas City Chiefs
so Christian Fulton is a pig here and
number 32 overall all right we are back
and the Bengals are on the clock to kick
off the second round here and I'm gonna
go we've been doing this these mock
drafts a lot when we do the second round
I know I've been guilty of this we start
it with let's get Joe burrow weapon but
now that it's happened guys you look at
it h aj green gets franchise tags
they've
invested a lot of money this year into
wide receiver because you have him in
Tyler Boyd you have a good running back
in jail mixing that can do everything
I'm actually gonna look at the defensive
side of the ball here and see a need for
a versatile linebacker like Zach bond
from Wisconsin now I know us three on
this show I've been vocal about it we
don't think he's this full-time edge
presence he does a lot of really good
things off the ball and I think for the
Bengals right now that's a really really
good fit for their defense so you might
sit here and go well don't you have to
help Joe burrow from day one I actually
think the Bengals did a really good job
of that so far
and there are a lot more picks in this
draft to be had to do that but Joe
burrow isn't coming in and throwing to
two Street free agents or handing the
ball off to a running back that was a
seventh or a sixth round pick he s
pieces there their offensive line is
getting some pieces back because they're
getting healthy so I think it's time to
help out the middle of the defense with
a player like bond is odd because we
haven't really talked about this I've
really thought about it - II just said
it Joe burrow is coming into one of the
better situations for a quarterback and
it's like the Bengals are the worst team
in football last year by record I think
a lot of it was injuries a lot of it was
the defense so getting a zach-bots in
there be a huge help for them I'm up
here at 34 the Colts have this pick from
Washington and a player that fell in the
first round we had normally assigned to
the Colts at times like Oh 13 Colts get
a quarterback well now 34 they're gonna
get that quarterback Jordan love fell
all the way through the first round for
us which i think is a little unrealistic
but again speaks to our individual views
of him I actually have Hema Johnson her
ranked very close and no traits like
Melo said so Jordan love falls here to
the Colts something telling about
Indianapolis I know a lot of fans would
be like we just signed Phillip Rivers
the Colts do not have a quarterback
under contract for the 2021 season
rivers were set whoever else they got no
one no quarterbacks so I do think that
we could see them at some point either
trade jacobi percent and so they are
freed up to do this or just acknowledge
and say hey we're gonna go into this
with a clean slate into 20 21 but if
Jordan love is here I think that's too
good to pass up
yeah I think so too if there's a
situation where he falls through the
second round I think the Colts
definitely jump on this pick number 35
overall the Detroit Lions
a lot of needs on this team I'm gonna go
with the defensive weapon type piece
again on the defensive line I really
like Marlin Davidson and we talked about
how there are no pro days and a lot of
teams haven't been able to get after
these guys Marlin Davidson had a great
performance in the Senior Bowl I really
like his versatility as a Matt Patricia
type guy to come in and play a lot of
different techniques on this defensive
line and help get after the quarterbacks
I still think that there's sneaky pick
fear for a running back again all of
them still sitting on the board wouldn't
surprise me if the Lions went here but I
think Matt Patricia will have his way
and he'll get a defensive guy at 36 the
New York Giants they invested a lot of
money into linebacker in this free
agency with Blake Martinez getting 10
million dollars a year Calif a crow
who's you know more of an outside
linebacker presence but Dave gentlemen
man when he goes after something he
doubles down this history has shown us
in Carolina it's shown it with the
Giants and I'm going linebacker here in
the second round and getting them
another piece a guy that there's still
room to start malik harrison from ohio
state
he is a Gettleman kind of player he's a
thumper in the middle he moves better
than I expected when you do watch the
film a really really good tackler so for
the Giants here at 36 after all that
money and free agency and a premium top
40 pick they feel much better about the
middle of their defense guys I am up
here 37 they lost Angeles chargers they
took a quarterback Justin Herbert in the
first round there aren't a lot of needs
that match what's on the board like I
would love to go left tackle here
there's not one we had six go in the
first round and as much as I like I say
Wilson he's a right tackle only so I
look at this team and say okay where
could I match value with need and it's
actually at corner in my opinion they
have they have some good corners I'm not
saying anything about Casey hair were to
Chris Harris here but they're a little
bit old at the corner position they've
also struggled to stay healthy so I'm
gonna go best player available here with
AJ Terrell from Clemson a guy who I
wrote this last week until the second
half of the national championship game
he had dominated all season long a
little player by the name of Jamar chase
just happened to get the best of him
yeah you know I'm up number 38 overall
the Carolina Panthers Panthers are
another team obviously they're picking
pretty high they have a lot of needs
Matt gave them Isaiah Simmons to start
this thing and when I look through their
depth chart I see a lot of good
potential
you know DJ more curtis samuel at
receiver obviously they've got a very
good running back they're making some
moves on the offensive line so i don't
know what the hell to do here i look at
the defense obviously just fill the need
corners are going off the board like
crazy so I'm gonna give them Kohl commit
to tight in they just lost Greg Olson
I think Cole commit can come in and be a
target for Teddy Bridgewater kind of a
safety after Christian McCaffrey is not
open but he also was gonna free up that
rushing lane I think he can do a lot of
things to help Christian McCaffrey be
more successful 39 the Dolphins finally
guys we have a running back come off the
board almost went through the top forty
without one that's just because DeAndre
swift is too good for the Dolphins here
yes he went out you know you get
somebody like Jordan Howard I understand
that Swift is a very very different
player so for Miami here you're getting
your one a running back at pic 39 a guy
I think is really the best running back
in this class a three down player and
when he's healthy he's a difference
maker a potential home run hitter and
make you miss kind of guys so for the
Dolphins at 39 you get your running back
at the future they've taken him at 18 I
wouldn't have been mad and you get him
at 13 he's that good
hell of a pick number 40 the Houston
Texans Billo Brad no idea what you're
doing here buddy but I'm gonna give me a
Clyde Edwards allaire I know they trade
it for David Johnson he's a backup in my
mind and apprehensive whenever that
exactly never healthy they need running
backs even with Duke Johnson
I think Edwards alaria is the type of
player that bill O'Brien's gonna look at
and say okay we got to give it a shot
Watson
some help he can catch very well out of
the backfield can open things up
offensively and honestly this is one of
those spots were what this team needs is
not available on the board right now
it's just the where the Texans have
holes there's not the value even if you
wanted to draft a receiver here I feel
like it would be a little bit of a
stretch for a Brandon I you Kirk AJ
Hamlisch so I went with a picking in
Edwards later I'm sure Texans fans won't
like but hey you guys don't like
anything your team does so this one
might be right speaking of teams and not
liking I'm up number 41 overall the
Cleveland Browns and I bet Browns fans
think I hate them I don't I really like
the Cleveland Browns and I have since
the Derrick Anderson days I just don't
like your quarterback but I'm gonna help
you out here
I'm gonna give you one of my favorite
in this entire draft and I have to do it
before Connor takes him I'm looking at
Antoine Winfield junior out of Minnesota
I think he's a do-it-all defensive back
he plays corner he's my slot corner both
safety positions this secondary is gonna
be tough I know there are some other
needs here but I really like Antoine
Winfield and I got it getting before
coming up
yeah I'm shaking my fist to your Melo is
that 42 the Jaguars I still want to
upgrade safety and I want to do it with
a versatile player which I believe
Winfield is so I'm gonna hope for a
bounce-back here from Grant Delpit this
is a player that I know I had in the top
ten top five before the season before he
fell off a cliff and just stopped
tackling or really doing much of
anything but the sophomore film is
first-round film and Jacksonville they
could still use a guy back there Delpit
has covered in the slot he has played
deep safeties played cover two he's even
played down really outside linebacker in
that front seven before as a Blitzer as
a run stopper he can handle any role and
I think Jacksonville is a team that can
get the most out of him and honestly if
you do that you're getting a much better
player than the 42 overall selection
would Delp it without a doubt I think
that the potential for Delpit to bounce
back is huge if he plays like he did
this last year at LSU he's not good
that's the only primarily an NFL player
right just a name but he's all pro if
you watch sophomore yeah he's one of the
more confusing players that I've ever
watched over to your stretch number 43
the Chicago Bears have this pick from
the Raiders Auto Adam trot minute tight
in
yeah Jimmy Graham's there no one cares
about that I don't know what Ryan pace
is thinking and signing Jimmy Graham
they still need a tight end
Adam Trotman we've said before it's like
a poor man's George kiddo he's violent
he's aggressive he's a blocker he's a
route runner he's very good after the
catch
so Adam Trotman should be your new
starting tight in Chicago Bears I don't
know Jimmy Graham I guess is your big
slot receiver at this point hell yeah 44
the Colts they already got their
quarterback of the future now so I'm
looking at team needs I want edge rusher
the best one on my board is a technician
reminds me a lot of Justin Houston
honestly I'm going Bradley and I to fit
into this defense and try to pressure
quarterbacks 45 the Bucs I know they've
made some free agency additions I still
think they need a future right tackle
I'm gonna go Isaiah Wilson here and
I think listen Tom Brady he's pretty old
I don't know if you guys have heard and
I know he could still throw the ball but
they're gonna develop a pretty good run
game behind him they're not gonna
aspirate e to drop back and throw the
ball 60 times a game and a guy that will
help in the run game is Isaiah Wilson
whether he wins that starting right
tackle job or not you can use him as a
sixth offensive lineman you could
develop him down the road he was a five
star out of Brooklyn for a reason guys
he is an absolute unit a very strong
player I thought he was good and passed
protection not great there's a
difference and one of the guys that got
him is Caleb on Chaisson that's okay
it's gonna happen so for the Bucks here
at 45 I'm comfortable taking the best
tackle on the board gotta be better than
Tamar Dodson at least long term number
46 the Denver Broncos you mentioned it
in round one Connor a receiver could be
a huge need for them I'm gonna give them
that in Brandon Iuka let him play some
in the slot let him play on jets pop
passes just get the ball in his hands
give drew lock that explosive playmaker
after the catch that is IU Quan I think
he's the best of the round two receivers
and I'm up again drafting for the Ravens
who I talked about earlier guys if this
next pick happens AFC might be one and
I'm giving the Baltimore Ravens Jonathan
Taylor I think that Mark Ingram is a
great running back he's also at the end
of his career pair him up with a guy
like Jonathan Taylor who I do think
can't catch out of the backfield and
it's a lot like marking room with a
little bit more speed I don't know if
they ever throw the ball again if you
have marking room and Jonathan Taylor
and I don't know if you ever need to
manage on 'litham taylor baltimore
jersey might be one of the best jerseys
to own in the NFL 48 at the New York
Jets thank you guys for letting me look
for them but with the Jets here 48 they
went tackle which I loved in the first
round Melo had them take Andrew Thomas
now you load up at wide receiver here
this pick might surprise people
KJ Hamlin from Penn State because he's a
smaller guy and they do have Jameis and
Crowder but this team just needs speed
they need somebody that can win
vertically down the field if they don't
bring back Robby Andersen they really
need somebody that can win down the
field
so for Hamlet here you're getting an
absolute rocket the drops are a little
concerning the routes need polish but
there's only so many true for three
players in the drafts that can really
make a play out of nothing with the ball
in their hands and that's why I like
Hamlet
and Arnold how about this one guys 49
the Pittsburgh Steelers this is their
first pick in the strap because they
trade it for Mika Fitzpatrick that
worked out really well so at 49 I have
the Pittsburgh Steelers taking Jalen
Hertz to be the successor to Ben
Roethlisberger love Doug Hodges cool
name awesome duck call not a great
quarterback get someone in there that
can now learn the system bhai Big Ben
who was hurt much of last year we've
said before this be a team that makes
sense for Jameis Winston but we don't
think they'll do it I think the team
that makes sense for Jalen hurts because
you have great great wide receiver
potential in this crew that they have
and now you have someone who can make
plays with his feet in the backfield
yeah I'd love to see the Steelers have a
quarterback that's mobile big band was a
pretty mobile quarterback early in his
career not like Jalen you missed Kordell
Stewart exactly like put him in 10 make
it happen Bears number 50 overall a lot
of needs for the Bears Matt you give him
a tight end to start off with I'm
looking at my board and I'm gonna give
him Kyle Duggar I like this safety I
think he's shooting up the board I think
he might even pass you grant to help it
for me when it's all said and done but I
like his athletic ability I like his
physicality I think he's a do-it-all
safety who's really only fault he came
from a small school this is so Ryan pace
we give them a guy from Dayton and a guy
from Lionel Ryan that's perfect Barry
who the hell you did a two-round mock
drafts I have no idea who these two guys
they're good at football yeah Oh Ryan
pace dream draft 51 the Dallas Cowboys
and I know they're fans have heard of
this guy Jalen rhaegar would just be an
explosive wide receiver for their
offense I've seen some people put him in
round one I'm not there yet I think the
drops are concerning I thought the the
40 and the combine was a little
underwhelming Frau explosive he looks on
the field but I still like him a lot I
really do I would take my 51 every
single time for the Dallas Cowboys here
you bring back a Mario Cooper on big
money like what you have in Michael
Gallup now you have your slot guy in
rhaegar for the future yeah I I get
accused of not liking rhaegar but I do I
just don't like him in the first round
they right here yeah great I probably
would have taken him with it the next
couple of teams that I have so I like
the value here 52
Los Angeles Rams they let go of Todd
Gurley you still need to run the ball in
Shaun McVeigh's office right this is a
Mike Shanahan offense at it's at it
core I'm gonna give him JK Dobbin so we
have a little bit of a run on backs here
Dobyns one of the most improved players
in college football a steer he catches
well in the backfield
he had explosive runs are his specialty
there are gonna be times where this dude
gets one two negative one yards boom 64
yards he's so good at the chunk play you
got to be a little patient with JK
Dobbins but it pays off big down the
field yeah and I think he proved that in
the college football playoff the Eagles
number 53 overall Connor gave him Justin
Jefferson in the first round looking at
team needs
I think secondary I know they've added
some pieces there but I think it's still
in need I'm gonna give him Ashton Davis
out of cow a burner at safety but I
think he can play almost every position
in that secondary and I think they're
gonna like that versatility in
Philadelphia 54 the bills they signed
some edge rush help in Mario Addison but
keep going in the second round there is
Terrell Lewis on the board here when
healthy he is a difference maker maybe
the bills are a team that can manage
those reps once again guys I don't know
how you would feel but if if Luis was
healthy full-time he had a chance to be
a lock as a top right edge it was class
so for the bills I think they're willing
to take that risk here and they built a
roster that can afford it yeah
absolutely
I love trellis we saw they do to the
senior bold day one it's like awesome oh
okay
that's what six five 265 looks like it
coming out of college it was it was
impressive 55 the Atlanta Falcons who
again got applauded the offseason that
they've had
I'm gonna go D tackle here I said in
round 1 hey I want to go D line here but
the values not there so I gave him CJ
Henderson coming back around you get
rust black lock here who a lot of people
believe could be a late first round pick
the way the board falls he's here at 55
overall so the Falcons walk out of this
thing looking real real good with CJ
Henderson and Ross black lock on a
defense which really completely remakes
what you've already done by adding Dante
Fowler yep number 56 overall again the
Miami Dolphins I'll tell you guys if
they don't walk away from this draft
with like three Pro Bowl guys they've
failed because they have so many picks
so early in this draft we've already
filled needs at tackle running back
linebacker quarterback I'm gonna give
them a receiver now Donovan people's
Jones out of Michigan I think he can
compliment what they're doing here and
it gives to a nice young target 57 the
Texans I don't know if God Himself can
save this team from Bill O'Brien but
we're gonna try here so Mac out them a
pretty good running back earlier on in
the round
I'm gonna go interior offensive line
Lloyd Cushing Barry you can move Nick
Mart and I think from Center to guard
and play cushion Barry at center so I
really like taking the best available
offensive linemen on the board for
Houston which means they'll probably
take a linebacker you know yeah yeah
Watson I'm praying for you man it's
something nonsensical force your way out
to Shawn before it's too late
number 58 the Minnesota Vikings up I
somehow got every pick for the Vikings
that never happens in these they say
boom boom boom it just spaces out I'm
gonna also go into your offensive line I
know they've drafted their a lot
recently and they've hit on some guys
but I still think they could get better
John Simpson from Clemson
watch him just Maul people in the run
game and you will fall in love a lot of
those Travis ETM plays where you see him
you know cut up the middle inside zone
and then bounce that's John Simpson
setting the table for him so give the
Vikings somebody that can help Dalvin
cook I think you'd be perfect for that
Gary Kubiak type offense here and
apparently there's a little bit of a run
going on with interior offensive line
I'm up with the Seahawks
and I think this was a different team
when their offensive line was healthy
last year so I do think they're gonna
need to address some depth here I'm
gonna take Tyler beer dish out of
Wisconsin I think he can start at center
I think he can develop a guard Seahawks
need to protect Russell Wilson you know
the guy can win you nine games now go
get him some help and protect him in the
playoffs 60 the Ravens just in this lown
a wrap round alone they've gotten
Jonathan Taylor now they get chase
Claypool who we don't know if he's a
tight end or a wide receiver and it was
a hell of a special teams player a hell
of a red zone threat he can absolutely
move down the seam so for that Baltimore
offense you are now adding adding it's a
quick - next to the MVP Jonathan Taylor
and chase Claypool in they really like
smiles Boykin last year and they took
him to the draft play fools teammate
they love tied in so I love that pic of
Claypool to rape one it's just like he's
a position was player in a good way
should say who cares what label he is on
Madden sled him gon be a mismatched
player he gets the defense every week
number 61 the Tennessee Titans Logan
Ryan has not been re-signed yet they
haven't need at corner so I'm gonna go
Noah they bit couldn't do it sometimes I
can say as I can't no it's a burn no I
know I've been agony big bonaga knee
that's deal I have notes which I don't
even try with the pronunciation but I
don't have the notes in front of me so
there we go
Logan Ryan though most likely gonna be a
cap guy who just can't come back because
the money they're giving to Ryan
Tannehill Derek Henry so I do think
corner getting a young corners a big
need for a team that they've taken some
like one-year risk low risk on edge
players on on defense but I think in the
secondary variables gonna try to stock
it to the draft
yeah and I'm up again I have the Green
Bay Packers kind of bringing this thing
to the end number 62 overall they've
been filling a lot of needs to be a free
agency and I know they brought in a guy
like Ricky Wagner but I think it's start
they need to start looking at that left
tackle of the future I'm gonna give him
Lucas nying a name that we haven't
talked about a lot but I like him at
tackle out at ECU a guy that can come in
and develop and then maybe replace at
left tackle
alright 63 your Chiefs here Melo and
this pick is from San Francisco I'm
gonna go Jordan Brooks you're kind of
playing the board right now and this is
an athletic linebacker for their front
seven
I think the Chiefs you you know
obviously address corner and round one
with Christian full and now you go here
with Jordan Brooks it's really just
about stocking up this defense on cheap
contracts because you're gonna have to
pay my home she paid Tyree kill you have
some money invested into the offensive
line at some point you need some value
too you don't need a great defense in
Kansas City you just need one that keeps
you afloat and I think the combination
of Brooks and Fulton help you do that
well I think they fit the mold because
one thing that we're gonna see Steve
spagnolo really value is smart players
you know guys who are athletic but smart
just don't make mistakes and Brooks and
Fulton both really fit that mold
Brooks is an incredible athlete that
would help in the middle 64 the Seattle
Seahawks the last pick an hour to around
mock draft guys we have seen them fill a
lot of needs here through your picks be
adesh jaylen Johnson I'm gonna go wide
receiver let's just add to a strength
they got pretty
lucky last year in this spot guy named
DK Metcalfe was the pick here I'm gonna
go low viscous Shane dolt
put him in there with Tyler Lockett and
Deacon Metcalfe and all the Titans that
they have it would only when all those
running backs get injured just slide him
in the back right I mean yeah there you
go give it up Ares Shane oh another guy
who's been a little bit banged up in
college didn't have the greatest you
know performance as we may be expected
him to have this year but I still
believe in him as a GAC player just find
creative ways to gaze upon names teams
are looking for a Deebo Samuel Levesque
Ishino has a little bit of Deebo to his
game all right that's our mock draft and
that is our show again we'll be here
three times a week still giving you guys
content and as much news as we get so
please stay home stay safe and take care
of each other will be back talk to you
tomorrow
for mellow for Connors Matt we'll talk
to you real soon